hey Karthi % oh yeah hey hey I came up
with a really great idea dude yeah I'm
gonna play both sides why would you tell
me that should enough Papa shut it cuz
if you trying to keep secret from me
well now I know there was a point during
my time with Assassin's Creed Odyssey
where I stopped caring how nonsensical
things got
despite ubisoft's obsession with
creating historically accurate settings
Assassin's Creed games have never been
that realistic but Odysseys mechanics
and narrative clash in so many ways it's
dizzying Cassandra will bounce between
allegiances on a whim she'll convince
loyal Spartan soldiers to join her ranks
in a matter of seconds and the romance
options are so flimsy and half-baked
it's comical yet somehow it all kind of
works in Odysseys favor if you haven't
been following Assassin's Creed Odyssey
its what you'd expect coming off of
origins you play as either Cassandra or
this guy I don't think anyone really
remembers his name and explore the Greek
islands during the Peloponnesian War you
assassinate targets explore the world
and climb lots of towers and temples
only to dive off into a pile of leaves
what's different about odyssey is that
Ubisoft his cramp is many features as
possible into this game
there's naval combat a branching
narrative a nemesis like system conquest
battles time quest romances engravings
and so on it's overwhelming on top of
this Odyssey tells a gripping story
centered around the protagonists family
ideally a game would try to weave all
these different features and mechanics
into the narrative in order to give them
context Assassin's Creed Odyssey does
none of this in fact Odyssey doesn't
even attempt to try to explain away its
inconsistencies shortly after you were
introduced to Cassandra or this guy you
beat up some thugs and by beat up I mean
you cut them apart with your dagger
until they are lying in a puddle of
their own blood moments later the very
same thugs get up and now you are given
a decision because that's a new thing in
this game you can either kill them or
let them live from that moment on I
should have known that Odyssey was
willing to throw logic out the window if
it had to these inconsistencies are so
prevalent that it borders on being
self-aware but never quite outright
addresses just how absurd this game is
hours later a Spartan asked me to fight
by his side to fend off the encroaching
athenian forces eager to prove my
loyalty i accepted i followed him to his
camp and approached him all I had to do
to initiate the quest was hit why I
lined myself up with the character and
pressed why unfortunately why is also
the same button you used to assassinate
and instead of a friendly conversation
Cassandra dug her spear into the neck of
a different nearby Spartan
within seconds the camp erupted did
before I could even process my actions
blades were flying through the air once
the dust settled I had slaughtered a
small florist of Spartan soldiers I
walked back to the quest giver and as if
nothing happened he greeted me and we
went into battle beating our chests not
long after without batting an eye I took
up arms with the Athenians and drove the
Spartans out of Corinth as Mac puts it
and it's always sunny in philadelphia I
was playing both sides and not really
keeping it a secret I'd say for the
first 10 hours or so I was trying to
rationalize my actions
maybe Cassandra isn't a well-known
mercenary yet I'm constantly swapping
armor so maybe they just don't recognize
me I kept trying to make sense of this
game until a horny old woman from
folkies asked me to bring her a bare
scrotum
she tells Cassandra that a deer's tongue
in a bear's scrotum is exactly what she
needs to revitalize her old and tired
husband I don't spoil anything but this
quest goes places he's my son when we're
together it's indescribable the
Assassin's Creed series has had plenty
of comedic moments but after finishing
this quest I was ready to accept
whatever this game throws at me while
Triple A games like Assassin's Creed
constantly chase realistic graphics
mechanically they are never that
realistic even some of the most grounded
games require you to suspend your
disbelief in some form or another
however it's a gap that some of the most
pronounced developers in the industry
are trying to close apart from its
meticulously crafted world Ubisoft has
made no attempt to do this oddly enough
Assassin's Creed Odyssey reminds me a
lot of an open-world game from 2008
called Saints Row 2 two years after the
original Saints Row two upped the ante
in almost every way unlike later
installments in the franchise
saints row two's narrative stayed
somewhat grounded and serious it did go
to some really dark places though like
chaining a guy to the back of your car
and driving around the city
however the dozens of side activities
and diversions range from car surfing to
streaking there is an overwhelming
amount of content most of which had
nothing to do with the events at hand
while you could argue that saints row
twos lighter tone allowed for all these
ridiculous activities it felt like
volition and THQ wanted it to be the
most feature-rich open-world game of the
time even if all the different parts
didn't quite coalesce while Saints Row 2
didn't quite blow critics away like Red
Dead Redemption or Grand Theft Auto 5 it
was an admiral game in its own right and
the same feels true for Assassin's Creed
Odyssey it feels like first and foremost
Ubisoft was trying to make an assassin's
Creed game fun rather than cohesive for
example you can't die from falling you
can take damage but you can never
outright die this may seem like a weird
decision considering the franchise was
built around climbing tall buildings but
Odyssey would rather have you explore
the world uninterrupted by loading
screens instead of thinking about how to
safely descend a mountain and if that's
not enough you have an ability that lets
you teleport to enemies in the blink of
an eye now I'm not saying Odyssey
shouldn't be criticized for its messy
tone its clashing mechanics and
nonsensical design it's important to
take a deeper look at these
inconsistencies and I can see why this
game would turn some people off it
presents you with a realistic world
pulled from history but then you're
teleporting around the map sticking your
magic knife into people's necks for me
though there's something refreshing
about playing a game where I was almost
encouraged to turn off my brain and just
accept all the ridiculous things that
were thrown at me
[Music]
you